après de longues tractations pour former
une équipe gouvernementale
mustapha adib a dû finalement jeté
l'épongé samedi depuis le palais
présidentiel de baabda il a annoncé sa
démission libanais et leur a présenté
ses excuses
alors que les efforts pour former un
gouvernement atteignez les dernières
étapes
je me suis rendu compte que l'accord sur
lequel j'ai accepté cette mission
nationale pendant cette période
difficile de l'histoire du liban
n'existe plus de plus la ligne
gouvernementale avec les spécificités
que j'ai mise a échoué je tiens à
l'unité nationale fondée sur la
constitution et sa crédibilité
je m'excuse de ne pas pouvoir poursuivre
la tâche de former ce gouvernement en
août à bahreïn rendent la tâche qui les
leur combat pour mustapha el dib la
cause de son échec à former un
gouvernement de ministres indépendants
et l'inexistence d'un consensus entre
les forces politiques du liban un pays
où les communautés essentiellement
musulmane et chrétienne se partagent le
pouvoir en fonction de leur poids
démographique
dans le détail mustapha à dives n'a pas
pu obtenir des chiites de nommer lui
même un ministre des finances représenté
par le hezbollah et le mouvement amal
les chiites tiennent absolument à ce que
ce poste clé tombe dans leur escarcelle
selon les observateurs la mauvaise
volonté du tandem chiite est liée aux
sanctions américaines imposées un
ministre du parti amal qui étaient aux
finances et à deux compagnies affiliées
au hezbollah en pleine finalisation de
l'accord résultat les négociations n'ont
pu aboutir
saâd hariri l'ancien premier ministre
libanais accusent les chiites sans les
nommer de ce fiasco
une nouvelle fois la classe politique au
liban dans nos mondes
un exemple criant de son échec dans la
gestion des affaires publiques et de son
approche de l'intérêt général
les libanais connaît ceux qui ont bloqué
la mission de mustapha adib et nous
n'avons pas besoin de les nommer car ils
se sont dévoilés au liban et sur la
scène internationale
pointée du doigt après cet échec les
chiites par la voix du chef du mouvement
amal et président du parlement dise
toujours croire en la feuille de route
des manuels macron personnes est aussi
attaché à l'initiative française que
nous mais il y a ceux qui l'ont nous
et en opposition avec tous les principes
établis l'initiative française porte
dans son essence des réformes et le
gouvernement est celui qui doit mettre
en oeuvre ses réformes après leur
approbation dans un pays ravagé par la
crise économique est fragilisée par la
double explosion survenue début août
dans le port de beyrouth le poste de
ministre des finances revêt une
importance vitale
d'autant que le fmi et plusieurs
bailleurs de fonds étrangers conditionne
l'attribution des aides à la mise en
branle des réformes structurelles